es la esperanza para los que no quieren
el regreso del movimiento al socialismo
carlos meza se presenta como el retador
de luís arce del fin de evo morales y
líder en las encuestas hombre de letras
mesa destaca por su perfil moderado y su
experiencia política y diplomática
primero un proyecto de futuro el único
proyecto de futuro viable como una cima
proyecto un programa sentido esto es lo
que necesita hoy más que nunca
pero su tono conciliador también le ha
valido críticas principalmente por no
mantener una confrontación directa con
el más algo que ha modificado en la
recta final de la campaña
sus seguidores niegan esa etiqueta de
tibio eso de dubitativo no tiene ningún
asidero es la guerra sucia que hacen
tanto de la derecha como de la izquierda
nosotros somos el centro democrático y
carlos meza demostrado que no no se
vuelca al sol que más calienta o al
viento que más sopla
sus detractores también recuerdan su
convulsionado paso por la presidencia
cargo que asume otro en la revuelta
social de octubre de 2003 y el que
renunció dos años después esto le resta
opciones entre sectores indígenas y
populares tras reunir el apoyo de la
presidenta interina jeanine áñez y del
ex presidente jorge quiroga quienes
retiraron sus candidaturas mesa espera
aglutinar el voto contrario al más
aunque no ha logrado la unión plena dado
que luís fernando camacho sigue en
carrera al igual que otros tres
candidatos
[Aplausos]